I'm tempted to ask him but our
experience in the theater so David did
you enjoy being Werner Heisenberg there
was a moment in the play where we accuse
him of not making the bomb because he
did not understand the physics and of
course he denies this the character
Heisenberg of course I understood the
physics and I had this moment where I
say the critical mass did you tell him
the critical mass and evident and
Heisenberg says yes I gave a number and
I say yeah what was the number and he's
all about a tongue and I say Heisenberg
you're over by a factor of 20 you never
get anything wrong how could you be over
by a factor of 20 s so that's the
question how could he be over by a
factor of 20 hi Alan yes I definitely
enjoyed playing Heisenberg to your bore
and the theater I think we both did it
was a wonderful play and we worked
pretty hard on learning the play and it
taught me a lot about Eisenberg and I
actually began to identify more and more
with Eisenberg as the play went on why
did he make a mistake you ask why did
Heisenberg mistakenly calculate the
amount of uranium necessary to make an
atomic bomb which was a very lucky
mistake as the Blake's
planes because it was one of the reasons
the Germans never developed the atomic
bomb I have no idea the play suggesting
Heisenberg sometimes does that he didn't
want to build a bomb so but I think that
he made a mistake and some of us still
are and his Bobby is bigger mistake was
not the redo the calculation and maybe
that was because he wasn't truly that
interested in building a bomb who knows
since I did identify more and more with
Heisenberg I'm willing to believe that
that was the case